you'll play this Matthew McConaughey
[ __ ] this has been beaten to death but I
think we have to watch it because it's
so funny it's like this [ __ ] that
[ __ ] way two famous people do where
they join a social media network and
they make it a way bigger deal than it
has to be like no one really gives a
[ __ ] that Matthew McConaughey's on
Instagram now I hated who would actually
like really care about that and he maybe
like a 50 year old mom in Ohio maybe
filtering the [ __ ] out of his images too
god damn dude this fourth post big
strike oh god it's his glasses on a
script the assess its process process
my first venture into sharing myself
from my views with the world and I'm a
little bit nervous about playing
character we pause it like I know I
won't have a monologue I'm not surely
wait this also this part is [ __ ]
great - what he says right after this
hold on dialogue what does that mean I
want to have a monologue I'm not sure I
want to have the dialogue that is the
ridge that's the most actor laugh I've
seen in a minute
goddamn that that means um he just wants
it to be about him but he doesn't want
to hear what other people have to say
this is like a big weird like this is my
first Open Mic speech I relate
everything to over mine that's all
that's what this is right here this is
my first time on the Internet first time
posting I just I made this mean and I
want y'all to be okay with it I mean the
funniest thing is that he thinks that
this is like softening the blow oh yeah
you know by making a weird video where
is like not looking at the camera and he
does my first for you know for my first
time trying to share things and about
myself and it's freaking me nervous dude
where are his lips man where did they
you got no lives in this frame dude
he's funny he's not he's not being
Matthew McConaughey's being Matthew
McConaughey on Instagram for the first
time yeah he's [ __ ] playing a
character yeah
and he's [ __ ] dude he looks face
tuned like this whole frame is just
[ __ ] weird-looking dude I hate this
man I hate this is the most actor [ __ ]
I've seen this like like North Hollywood
like plain white door that he has in the
background like all this [ __ ] is so la
and I feel like there's five people
behind the camera right now they're like
yachting oh yeah yeah totally right you
know when pee you got to have them on
like that that's it I was you know when
like people like in like who don't live
in major cities like in the
Midwest in the south and she like make
fun of like actors and stuff and they're
like all you Hollywood [ __ ] idiots
you're all more I understand because
they post [ __ ] like this yeah it's like
it's like anyone should look at this and
go yo get the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] off the
airwaves dog that [ __ ] is trash that's
that's is the uniform response to this
kind of [ __ ] this is awful man what just
just do it then just do it just do it
why you got to talk about it
that's just ruins the whole thing where
I gotta get meta with it I'm looking
forward to seeing if it translates
what's definitely not translating right
now no no because this is weird as [ __ ]
in bro
like you what do you think bro you think
people care about your one post and then
your to put gives a [ __ ] don't give me
people post on this [ __ ]
everyone is posting all the [ __ ] time
[ __ ] your post tell me now yeah with the
amount yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] online like
your post you know how many posts I'm
looking at her today but do you know
what my purposed my booking is like 700
post per hour
dude yes [ __ ] that scroll Twitter that's
like at least 50 oh yeah at least in
what 20 seconds I guess rush 50 [ __ ]
dude bruh so my post per minute right
now hundred at least I mean and that's
not it that's just casual browsing at
ppm is like 600 on weed 600 yeah easy
and you think I'm gonna stop for your
[ __ ] predict for this if it is your
funny bone it makes you think a second
makes your heart swell no I'm out of
here
take swell up you think you're gonna
post something on Instagram that's gonna
make my heart swell up yeah yeah nah nah
I've never looked at a single post on
Instagram and even ever felt anything I
mean I've never looked at a post on
Instagram and had a feeling I just like
it's purely just like yeah this should
happen that's it no one has ever made
something that maybe go haha
visit me on Instagram 50 post yeah just
50 yeah yeah not a single [ __ ]
thought or emotion or anything it's just
colors yeah it's all it is to me is it
colors yeah yeah yeah repost them yeah
yeah and be like lol I'm here [ __ ]
yeah that would have been hard as [ __ ]
hard as well that would have made some
OD field that would have tickled my
funny ball yeah my heart would swell
about this [ __ ] man man the value of a
post to make you go check in with em in
the e yeah what the em in the e me oh
man let's take it something else man I
think it's something else but no Matt I
can tell you right now you're not gonna
pose anything that makes me go oh [ __ ] I
think about me right now the only thing
that does that no I gotta check in with
me yeah the only thing that does that is
porn porn makes you go whoa after the
fact
yeah that's you've done that's when you
gotta check in with yourself like and
maybe maybe I did play too much for
tonight yeah I'm and then you're looking
at your fortnight cause play stepsister
yeah [ __ ] her dad yeah you know and
you're like yeah this is anyway I gotta
check in with me yeah yeah oh you got a
little take a little walk check in with
the M in the e yeah hopefully all those
things let's have some fun with it
though and this that's again let's keep
the heii that's low aye aye aye
what what does that mean no you know
what this is dude wait what does that
mean actually keep the high I not the
low I the high I don't know looking up
looking up to God [ __ ] positivity
your third eye there's so many ways you
can interpret that yeah
poetry dude yeah straight up unreal so
I'm gonna say this this is just someone
this is a famous person who has
never been on the Internet this just
screams I don't know what the internet
is this is like when your uncle is like
you know so I retired last year
you know I'm 47 buddy I'm thinking I
want to start at YouTube mm-hmm
you know but I'm just a you know I'm
just not sure how to approach it
what do you think I should do
you're like just said just put something
on there yeah but the people and how
they interpreted I mean like why do you
handle people well they don't like what
you make well you got to get there first
yeah it's just like just do something
and you'll learn well I want to go to
his saves story called prescription hold
on
I'm thinking he's never been on the
internet before but you know because
he's so busy reading scripts all the
time ah cuz that's the process got it
yeah you got to think yeah can't think
of how long he spends all day on the
setting conceiving new characters on the
process I mean that's the process yeah
you know yeah and that to me is the most
interesting thing his idea is is is
diving into it's his commitment to to
his craft to the craft and to the art of
acting and the process and that's me
keeping the high I not the low rather
than hello I keep it high dick up yeah
you're Rumple foreskin Cyclops hi uh
yeah not your [ __ ]
hello I know I I'm gonna call jerking
off from now on checking in with them
and they check in the end swinging in
the am and yeah she she checked my M&E
check in with the M in the you know we
was we was kissing and it was getting
sexy then I said why don't you check in
with them in the and she did the [ __ ]
are you saying man she sucked your dick
what does that mean yeah she does he
suck mine she's that like just say that
Allah dude his save stories look so
funny just called howdy
prescriptions and howdy howdy 1 points
seven million Oh bro is killing it yeah
he's doing all right
he's a husband a father an actor a
Minister of Culture a professor a
creative director
Austin FC whatever the [ __ ] that is Jake
a livin and pickle expert Oh Oh little
bit of personality there yeah I like
that
by your hearts well a little bit yeah by
your nine your preceding nine titles and
accolades I would not have guessed that
you're one for pickles I mean a human
eyes is in a little bit it does yeah
collects burger likes pickles
you guys like pickles you know every
does everyone oh you guys like pickles -
I like pickles I'm like you except I'm a
[ __ ] a list celebrity
you